oh!
best game
of all time
*heroic music starts playing*
what game...
*pauses to remember what he was going to say*
has such amazing gameplay
a story so deep and complex that few people can actually understand it?
i'm talking of course about "Bayonetta"
but anyone who plays it for the story or the gameplay is clearly lying
*giggles*
i think this is gonna be an awesome let's play
it's been a while since we did an older game
this is a game that i'm really really excited about, i can't wait to play this
and uhhh hopefully by the end of it Marzia will still stay with me *giggles again*
i should warn you tho....
don't flag this video please
the game is very confusing at start but i think once we get going
it'll be a very interesting daily let's play
so if you enjoy please do leave a like, i really apreciate it, it helps out a lot
and uhhh here you go *kisses the invisible you*
alright fine, get closer
*TONGUE*
yeah fucking perv-
let's get wrrrright into the bewbs!
*up there ^ just, look ^ there ya go*
where is the ass and the titties?
what is this, sailor moon?
so i don't know anything about the story so i'm gonna try my best t-
ohhh my god fuck the story
je- oh.... oh it gets better!
this is the greatest story of all time
OH MY GOD IT NEVER ENDS what the fuck is that?!
that was a fucking cow bulge, oh my god edit that out (we won't)
i'm sorry that was too much
jesus christ
i did not expect that OH MY GOD i get to play right away!
yeaaaaah i love when the games d-
oh my god i'm naked!
best game!
oh there's a story going on the background
i could not care less honestly, i'm sorry *giggle*
i just hear bewbs and ass
i don't knooow what's going on, but i love it
and this is the greatest game of all time
jesus christ, what the fuck how could the Wii U perform all this shit
nice ass shot, i appreciate that thank you very much
okay
and now the game turned into, uhhh... a mecha, of course!
of course
WHAT THE FUCK IS GOING ON
I can fly and shit
look at this, hah!
*small laugh*
i don't know, oh my god shit happens all the time
how can you keep up with this?
jesus!
what the fuck is that?!
a fucking umbrella?!
i got shot by an umbrella, awesome
Bayonetta do something!
she did it
oh my god more sexy ladies
fuck yes (don't tell marzia)
that is the most japanese sound effect of all- oh my GOOOOD
oh my god she's british
that's hot as balls
Marzia please don't leave me
oh my god
oh my god don't scratch your beautiful face
oh thank god
oooooh that's a great shot
*inhales, surprised* oh my goood who is this?
whaaaat?
oh i wish my eyes could do that, can we do that effect?
*gives you a sexy look* was that cool?
thank you
"Present Day"! okay!
it takes place in 2016, that's cool
of course he puts on the monocle
aaand that gives him strength
*recreating this face: o_o* don't question us just go with it
that's the first rule of Bayonetta
oh my god what the fuck?
it's ca- *laughs*
that guy literally looked like a pig
you can tell this game is japanese just by looking at the style
...or maybe this giant SEGA logo should be kind of a giveaway
Nintendo as well
well
who the hell is this guy?
oh my god
heeeey there she is!
*giggles*
*what the hell?!*
christmas?
i love her accent!
"beSIDES"
i-i'd do that, i'd volunteer
*dances*
*dolphin pewds?*
oh my!
Sounds like a lot of nasty shit
i'm into it
*giggles* that's not how you walk by the way *tries to walk like him*
"fuhGET ABOUT IT"
eyy!
heyy!
how is he carrying all those baggages?
it's making me anxious as fuck
what?
oh my goooOOO- *laughs*
*sniff* jesus!
of course she caught all of them, no problem
and then just throws them!
oh my g- *laughs*
oh my god i think their periods are synced
i...i *laughs*
fuhgetaboutit!!
Is Bayonetta a kid's name?
mm hm
now make out please (pewds is gettin all crazy)
they're definitely talking about their vaginas I'm sorry
oh you saw the shadow
the what?
god, so elegant
they both have british accents
why are they in New York? I don't understand, I have so many questions (headache starts)
oh my god
*giggles*
so Japan why couldn't she just drive off *laughs*
okay
what's up with the jets?
what's the matter?!
*Stares awkwardly at the camera*
what is his monologue? *giggles*
the guy is just thinking, "what the fuck i'm not paid for this"
this guy is my mentor
*giggles*
what?
oh, he got his jet alright
oooh, my gooood~
Japaaann~~
OOOOOOOH
sHIT
DID SHE JUST KICK IT???!!
EH
OH
and now it flies?
who's steering it?
i don't understaaand ;-;
oh my god, is this like the sailor moon thing?
is this like the sailor moon thing?
oh my god
*nosebleed*
O H!
MY GOD!
WAH!
AH
AAAAH
OHMYGOD
J E S U S
O H
BEST GAME!
OF ALL TIME
OH SHEEZ
i can't, i can't play this
i can't
O H!
it keeps happening
i'm
i'm crying
it's so beautiful
*oh my god what the fuck*
*alright, okay, whew*
*collect your thoughts, pewds*
ugh
ohmygod
yes
what the-
*laughs*
i don't even, i'm not even playing, and i'm totally fine with it
that was the best cutscene of my life
i'm gonna regret this video, i know it *laughs*
it plays beautifully, i fucking love it
just punches- SEEYA
*fabulous voice activated*BUTTERFLY WINGS!
YEAH!
FUCK OFF
WOO
ohmygod
i love the music (is that it, pewds?)
did it crack? did it crack somewhere? oh they- dammit
the guns broke
dammit car
oh my god, what is happening
oh my god
*more: o_o*
is that, who i think it is?
*laughs*
OH MY GOD YES
IT'S BLACK SANTA
he, he takes the kids' presents
instead of- fuck it, it wasn't funny
i'm sorry *giggles*
*small laugh*
what a fucking badass- how did he start the car??
FORGETABOUTIT
oh he, he drives the....the walls
that's *shrugs* why not?
SANTA CLAUS GOT US NEW GUNS!
FUCK YEAH
oh is she gonna transform again? please
aw, dammit
she's got fucking, guns on her heels
oh my god, fuck yes
that's literally my face, of playing this entire game
i- *giggles*
*laughs*
BEAUTIFUL
oh my god
this game is ridiculous, i fucking love it
oohhh, alright, i can be naughty.. (pewds no)
OH, I'M NAKED (It wouldn't be the first time on this channel)
AAND, OH OKAY, SO I USE MY CLOTHES
TO PERFORM ATTACKS
G-GENIUS
only Japan would think of that, wouldn't they?
OH, HERE WE GO
BYE BYE, BITCH >:D
AAAAH
FUCK YEAH
never been this happy in my life, i'm not joking
this is like, literally christmas for me
as a kid
ohmygod
fuck yeah
it's so fucking badass!
jesus!
oh she's back
i don't know how to keep up with this, it's so much shit happening all the fucking time
of course a dragon would ff WHERE DID THAT EVEN COME FROM??
i know i'm not good at the game
but, i'll get better, alright? don't worry about it
OOH SLAP DAT ASS
torturer attack
OOOHOOOHH YEAH
SLAP DAT- *laughs*
*laughing*
OH
YES
GET IN THERE, SLAP DAT ASS
YEEAAAHHH
that's right a nice bootay
that's what i'm talkin' about
they keep coming
what is that- oh god
what just happened? aw shit we're going down
we're going down
jesuS
i gotta jump
okay- WHOOP
WHOOP
BUTTERFLY JUMP!
badass
oh we got a silver that was fuckin' beautiful
okay.
jesus christ
jesus christ i gotta *deep inhale, exhale*
*the sound of satan himself*
gonna end the first part there, if we keep this going, i would really appreciate your support
if you leave a comment and a like (what about subtitling? huh?)
lemme know if you want more, i would LOVE to play more of this
uh, it's a fucking blast, this is so my type of game
uuh, and, uuh, hopefully further on we can get into the story and all that stuff
so let me know if you'd like more, like i said, i'd love to do it
and, i'll make the episode longer as we go, i like to start the first one off a little shorter
that's it for me for now though
thank you so much for watching, i hope you enjoyed
and as always *kissu the hand* stay awesome bros *brofist*
щ(ºДºщ)
ლ(ಠ_ಠლ)
щ(ಠ益ಠщ)
щ(ಥДಥщ)
(ಠ_ಠ )
(╯°□°）╯︵ ┻━┻
ᕙ(⇀‸↼‶)ᕗ
BYE